ukraine state emergency service says a
fire at europe's largest nuclear plant
has now been put out the fire at the
saporitia facility began after it came
under attack by russian forces local
officials say the plant has been safely
secured now the international atomic
energy agency says radiation levels
remain unchanged it has activated its
full emergency response mode because of
the situation at the plant the plant
produces a quarter of ukraine's energy
needs
president vladimir zelinsky has accused
russia of trying to repeat the chernobyl
disaster saying the incident underscored
the need to stop the fighting
yet if there's an explosion
that's the end for everyone the end for
europe
europe would have to be evacuated
only urgent action by europe can stop
the russian troops do not allow the
death of europe from a catastrophe at a
nuclear power plant
for more let's bring in dr charles casto
he's a u.s nuclear safety expert who is
involved in containing the fukushima
nuclear disaster in japan dr costa
thanks for being with us tell us what
went through your mind when you heard
that this ukrainian nuclear power plant
was on fire
well obviously terry that's a very
troubling situation that there is no
rational reason for uh attack on a
nuclear power plant
tell us how dangerous it is to have a
war being fought near a nuclear power
plant
well obviously
that situation is troubling however as
you've seen with the state media talking
about uh that it's stable the operators
are able to deal with these types of
situations we've planned for these
situations and
and the design of the plan is very
robust nevertheless that is not a
challenge that you want to present to
anyone to any operator in any nuclear
facility anywhere
what exactly
do you have to watch out for i mean if
tanks are firing even if
if they're not targeting the plant
itself but somewhere near it if a shell
hits the nuclear power plant what could
happen
the most troubling situation would
likely be with the spent fuel that's
that's stored in the facility and that
spent fuel is contained and has the
containment structure around it but
nevertheless is the part of the plant
and part of the fuel system that you
would have to worry about and we saw in
the fukushima case where they actually
the earth attacked the fukushima nuclear
plant that the operators were able to
maintain safety of the
spent fuel facility
is there any international arrests and
so
sorry go ahead sir the reactors have
been obviously very well very robust and
contained uh deep in the plant and and
it would be difficult to have us to have
a
serious uh release however that's uh
something we always are concerned with
the spent fuel pools are somewhat more
uh concerning
and as i said that we have been shown
demonstrated that we can protect spent
fuel pools
is there any international safety
protocol for something like this for
nuclear power plants in conflict zones
the
iaea has a response center the
department of energy the nuclear
regulatory commission the united states
and many other agencies and they have
been activated
to monitor the situation and there is
remote
monitoring of the radiation levels to be
able to determine the severity of the
accident or the concern that we have in
ukraine
but it's not such that when when
fighting is happening around a nuclear
power plant it's not that they shut it
down
yes typically what would happen is
as if it was a hurricane or a
tsunami uh prior to that the plants
would be shut down and safely secured at
that point then all you then what you
have left is the fuel itself
which would be protected but the plan
itself would likely be shut down or
would be shut down by the loss of
external power outside the facility the
plants are all likely shut down and
secured now many people not just in
ukraine uh many people are scared about
this situation with ukraine's nuclear
power plants being in the middle of a
war zone
should they be concerned
well you should be concerned the the uh
the likelihood of uh it depends on the
magnitude of any attack that might occur
the uh
and as i've said it's very extremely
robust the plant's extremely robust and
and mostly it would be a uh
area as we saw at chernobyl and
fukushima would be an area around the
plant that would be most uh susceptible
to damage
however after fukushima and after
chernobyl we learned a lot of lessons
from those accidents and learned many
countermeasures that we can take to
minimize the amount of radiation release
from a reactor regardless of the
accident that might occur
dr casto thank you very much that was dr
charles casto he's a u.s nuclear safety
expert
thanks gary
russia's media watchdog said friday it
had restricted access to several
independent media websites including
deutsche bello the tightening of control
over the internet comes just over a week
after russia invaded ukraine access to
websites of deutsche bella bbc and
various independent russian news app
websites are being
limited
well let's take a closer look at events
in russia with dw russian affairs
analyst constantine egert he joins us
now from tartu in estonia constantine
russia has been restricting access to
independent media can people in russia
still get uncensored information about
the war
yes terry but it's increasingly
difficult just
actually 15 minutes before i went on air
several reliable russian twitter
personalities in whose
the diversity of whose reports i can't
doubt uh started saying that twitter
is now probably
in the process of being blocked and you
can't open your twitter feed unless you
use uh vpn or tor or any other sort of
bypassing
device
so it seems that we are at least it
starts to look
as if russia is uh moving towards a
complete uh blockade of uh at least
social media uh apart from probably the
uh the the russian social media like
contact which is a russian version of
facebook uh which is essentially
controlled by the government that's
controlled by the fsb the russian
security service where contents unwanted
content can be removed so
uh i think that we've entered very
quickly a stage in which russia is kind
of rolling
back in time or rather trying to catch
up with china which as you know had
internet censorship from day one
so the people in russia are being
increasingly isolated along with the
government do we see
we do see some people however protesting
around the country in russia constantine
how risky is that for them
well it is very risky uh
the lower house of parliament
adopted amendments to the uh criminal
code which now punish something that's
very vaguely called fakes about the
russian special operation and actions of
the russian armed forces with up to
attention up to 15 years in prison
so that's not a joke
this is something
quite significant although
application
of this uh of this law
uh will probably be
quite lex because what you characterize
is fake so it's anything that does not
conform to the government line and i
think that uh this will be
quite problematic to put in jail
everyone but usually what putin's people
do they
uh they
imprison someone
um so that everyone else
will fear the outcome and we'll keep
silent
we're hearing rumors constantine that
the duma may decide to impose martial
law um
any truth to that
also the duma is the uh
it has to be both houses of parliament
to do my the federation council
but um i think that
for now it doesn't look likely because
there's a procedure
and putin is a stickler for legal
protocol it has to be i think a warning
of about 48 hours
before uh such uh
such measure is taken
uh and it has to be really approved by
the parliament i think the parliament
will approve because just a kind of
pocket institution put his [ __ ]
parliament but i think maybe
uh they are trying to bypass it by just
blocking independent information because
martial law is actually imposed only in
a situation where there is imminent
danger to russian sovereignty and
territorial integrity
doing that
will be admitting that something is
badly wrong and all the official reports
are actually lie
i want to tell you terry that the last
time russia was under martial law was
during the second world war so it's
going to be momentous and it's going to
be very very problematic for putin both
from the point of view of his image and
actually from the point of view of
keeping the country together after that
because
as we've seen uh it's not a very
competent military planning so i think
that maintaining at the same time
martial law at home
and
a combat operation essentially
prosecuting war abroad
i don't think that the putin system as
is as resilient
as to withstand such pressure
well that resilience will be tested with
international sanctions beginning to
bite the ruble in free fall
russians themselves are hearing even
from their own government that hundreds
of russian soldiers have been killed
the ukrainians say it's in the thousands
with these reports of the horror of war
coming out and the sanctions beginning
to bite is opposition to putin and the
war likely to grow in russia
i think yes you don't expect revolution
tomorrow although in russia nothing is
impossible absolutely nothing maybe
speaking now and then in an hour we'll
be analyzing completely something else
uh but but i think that there were two
things which were
sort of markers for me personally
one is uh the fact that the board of
directors of luke oil which is one of
russia's largest oil companies and
oldest actually
issued a collective statement
saying that this war should end
it's a bit timid but it's very clear
what they're talking about and this is
amazing because all such companies are
completely blind and completely kind of
following the kremlin line the fact that
a board of directors saying that not
just someone with individual conscience
i think that's that's probably a
precursor of quite a few things like
that to come and secondly ikea
sees its operations in russia from today
and yesterday scenes you may watch it on
youtube scenes of actually people in
moscow mobbing ikea
that was a site which i never thought
i'm going to see in my life so the first
if you wish
the first people who will feel the
sanctions will be business as well as
the city big city middle classes whose
life will never be the same as long as
the sanctions are there i think
eventually sanctions will start biting
all other classes of russian society
because uh
russian uh uh sort of food stuffs and uh
and drinks and even seeds for uh
for the agriculture a lot of it is
important and a lot of it is now being
sanctioned so it's going to bite
it's not probably going to be the
collapse of the states but i think that
many many many millions of people will
feel that their life has changed
irrevocably
constantine thank you very much that was
our russian affairs analyst constantine
egot
numerous cities are under heavy
bombardment by russia but still remain
under ukrainian control the black sea
port of casson is the only major urban
center to fall since russia began its
invasion more than a week ago ukraine
and the u.s accused russia of
deliberately hitting civilian targets
during its attacks
meanwhile civilians all over the country
strengthened their resolve to fight back
all over ukraine people are getting
ready to fight
in levif those with combat experience
teach those who have never held a gun
before
i came here to get some understanding of
what to do how to defend myself and how
to survive if the enemy comes
and while it's still calm in levee
devastation elsewhere could give an
indication of what could come this is
what the outskirts of kiev look like
with russian forces advancing in the
east and south president vladimir putin
claimed that his so-called special
military operation is going to plan
russian soldiers and officers are acting
bravely like true heroes our troops
fight with persistence and full
understanding that their cause is right
in the south russian troops and their
tanks have taken control of the key
black seaport of her son
they are also pressuring the port city
of mariopol
there's no water or electricity in the
depths of winter
to the east ukraine's second largest
city here is still standing despite
russia's advances but heavy bombardment
has left buildings and ruins and dozens
of civilians dead
if we fall
god forbid
next will be latvia lithuania estonia
georgia moldova poland
and then they will go to the berlin wall
a second round of talks between russian
and ukrainian negotiators has met with
some progress as the two sides agreed to
establish humanitarian corridors in some
areas
for those residents who have not or
could not yet escape any such corridors
could provide some desperately needed
respite
dw correspondent matthias berlinga is in
ukraine he's in live in western ukraine
matias how are people reacting to the
news first of all of that fire at the
nuclear power plant are they worried
of course people are worried about the
news of that uh
of that fire of that power plant um uh
ukraine is the first country that has
experienced uh a nuclear meltdown the
chernobyl plant is just 100 kilometers
north of kiev that exploded in 1986
and people do remember this so um
definitely there are a big worries about
that the news there were shocking for
the past few days people have gathered
around that power plant to protect it
people unarmed people
blocking the roads to that power plant
in the case that somebody would come
there yesterday shelling was reported
from these
places from these roadblocks that the
people have uh um
they haven't set up roadblocks they have
been standing there with their bodies to
protect the
the power plant so and then they moved
uh uh barricades in in in
on the roads mostly like vehicles and um
and uh yeah this is of course shocking
people have been aware of this risk for
some time
mathias uh give us the situation give us
the latest on the situation in ukraine
where do things stand this morning
lots of things going on um
as every day mario paul is still uh
encircled and uh under siege and uh
kiev's attacks on kiev are being
are ongoing in the suburbs of kiev and
there is the fear that russia might try
to lay siege on that capital as well
that's the news this morning
what about people fleeing their homes uh
i understand that there i mean over a
million people have left the country but
there are there must be a tremendous
amount of displaced people within
ukraine
of course there are a lot many people
who have fled their hometowns and are
now traveling either towards the western
border or towards the southern border so
it's the borders with poland slovakia
hungary and romania
many people have left the country as you
said mostly women and children because
men are prevented from leaving the
country under martial law so
many men or families who do not want to
split up are remaining inside the
country in these safer areas for example
here and leave where i am now which is
one of the main escape routes out of the
country towards poland
now ukraine and russia held another
round of talks yesterday they agreed on
humanitarian corridors for people to
leave tell us about those
it's humanitarian courages they're there
for people to leave but they're also to
bring in supplies into the cities to
feed
the civilian population to
medication and all these humanitarian
needs there is for example uh i i
haven't seen any very specific uh
ideas or plans to to establish these
corridors i think the main thing is that
they have agreed on establishing them at
all but for a city like mariupol for
example that has been under siege for
quite some time now
this would is of course something that's
very important and
we
the electricity is shut off their
heating is shut off there and no
supplies coming into the city so this is
of course a very dire situation for this
city and a corridor is extremely bad is
badly needed
matthias thank you so much uh matthias
berlinga their correspondent in libby
all over ukraine it's civilians bearing
the brunt of this military bombardment
and as we just heard from matthias for
those in front-line cities like mario
paul the situation is intensifying for
many the humanitarian corridor may come
too late a warning this report contains
disturbing images
another shell hits mariupol as medics
wait for their next call
but with phone services knocked out in
parts of the city they don't always know
where to go
often they go door to door
searching for anyone injured and in need
of treatment
here they find an elderly woman
her house was hit by a shell
she's still in shock as she's taken by
ambulance to a makeshift hospital
but sometimes help comes too late
doctors were unable to save a
16-year-old boy struck by a bomb that
exploded on a football field
far away from the fighting a plane
carrying medical supplies has arrived in
the polish capital warsaw
the world health organization has sent
36 tons of aid including surgical
materials to treat a thousand people
if the military conflict escalates we're
going to see
many many more really vulnerable people
who are running away
who will need a lot of support
but first the cargo will have to be
transported by road to places where the
aid is urgently needed
the supplies will be moved into truck to
the border with ukraine and then further
to support the affected health system
that means it'll likely be days before
the medical shipments reach frontline
cities
in mariupol which is under siege by
russian forces and cut off it's already
too late
meanwhile the exodus of people fleeing
the war continues mainly women and
children as most ukrainian men are
required to stay behind to fight
poland is receiving the biggest number
of refugees but other neighboring
countries are also taking in people
desperate to escape russia's assault
dw's tessa walter reports from the
slovakian border with ukraine
a roof over their heads
even if it's just a tent and a hot meal
here in vishna nemyetsky slovakia they
found shelter from the attacks of the
russian army in their homeland
oksana arrived here from western ukraine
just a few hours ago with her two
children
i was so afraid for my children
[Music]
we had to flee
all of us had to flee
i don't know what to do now
oksana is relieved that she's safe here
for the time being
but she still can't comprehend the whole
catastrophe of the wall
i don't want to call myself a refugee i
want to go back home where my children
were happy
[Music]
i'm just so scared
lydia also just made it across the
border with her children
she's afraid for her husband who can't
be with his kids right now but has to
fight the russian soldiers
we are all worried but what should we do
my husband told us to go and then we
went
we may never see each other again
this is not right if we all have to die
we want to die together
it's not right that my husband is in
ukraine and we are here
you don't want to leave your home
like lydia and oksana thousands of women
and children are fleeing ukraine for
neighbouring countries
the families here are trying their best
to hold up
especially the mothers do all they can
to shield their children from the
horrible situation they are in
but when you speak to them a little bit
longer you realize just how traumatized
they are by the war in their home
country
marian letso is one of the volunteers
who takes care of them
their said is not very surprising
because yesterday they had normal lives
and today they are here in slovakia and
i believe they didn't plan to come here
so it's different for them they have
different lives now
for now they can only wait until their
feet will be on solid ground again
joining me now is james elder he's a
spokesperson for the united nations
children's fund unicef in liv
james tell us what does this war mean
for ukraine's children
very much what your viewers just saw
deep trauma uh separation from families
fear
and for an increasing number it means
the end of their life we are seeing
children being killed and injured in
this conflict as things continue to
escalate so across the board this is
nightmarish for children for very large
numbers of children
how can children begin to process the
hell of war as you say it's traumatizing
traumatizing enough for adults how do
children deal with it
you know i speak to so many mothers here
and it's a mix some some babies sleep a
lot more as a coping mechanism some are
in tears some are just frozen frozen and
steely
uh
others
console their own mothers when their
mothers can no longer keep up that uh
that facade of that that strength so
it's a whole gamut of things and it's an
area that unicef knows from yemen to
afghanistan now to ukraine i cannot
believe we're seeing another nation
children learn what conflict looks like
what an air raid siren is but we know
that the quicker this this trauma can be
addressed the less chance it has of
scaring these children of course beyond
our own efforts the best way to end this
trauma is to end this fighting
what's being done to help these children
james
a lot a lot by everyday ukrainians i'd
like to start by saying grandmothers on
the street cooking foods gifts of
blankets to medicines teenagers offering
shelters for people who are coming in
and have spent nights in bunkers and now
are trying to flee unicef we have mobile
child protection teams that will go both
sides of the conflict line as you and i
speak we're trucking in emergency
supplies from our global hub in denmark
that are coming in to where i am to
ukraine now
safe spaces along those long journeys a
lot but it's important to remember as
long as this conflict continues that
demand will continue to outstrip the
supply as your reporter said of half a
million children fleeing their country
in seven days that's unprecedented in
scale and swiftness and and to be honest
unprecedented in sorrow and stress
now we're seeing most of these children
arriving at the border uh at ukraine's
border to the surrounding countries with
their mothers but some of them are
unaccompanied where will all these
children end up
yeah it's a very good question and it's
a very worrisome area
of work now
on a policy level unicef is very clear
on what inter-country adoption should
look like in the best interests of the
child and ukraine and those neighboring
countries are clear on these guidelines
so we ensure as best we can they're with
a family member an extended family
member someone from their village these
things are key and then as a next resort
to find a safe place somewhere this is
not difficult this is not easy rather
given the enormity of number numbers of
people moving but this is what unicef is
seeking to do on all those border
regions remembering of course there are
tens of thousands of children in
orphanages here that's a great concern
because we've had reports that they're
in the line of fire or even children in
hospitals i was at a children's hospital
here yesterday children in icu intensive
care on drips how do we get them out how
do we get them to safety
what about the long-term psychological
effects james is the trauma that these
children experience likely to haunt them
as adults
yes it certainly can if you look at that
they've spent nights in bunkers as a
little girl told me there were rats in
the bunkers but her mummic said that
explained but there's no bombs sofia
yeah yes it is again that the sooner we
can get out of this situation the better
but
they will need to be counseling they
need temporary learning spaces they need
any type of education that can give them
a distraction
um whether we unicef deals with this
situation from yemen to afghanistan to
ethiopia the longer these things
continue the more chance it has of
scarring this is a young nation a very
from what i see a very entrepreneurial
nation these children will add so much
value
to any society but of course they want
to add it to their own home they want to
add it to ukraine
james thank you very much for talking
with us this morning that was james
elder from unicef
and if you're just joining us you are
watching dw special coverage of russia's
war on ukraine i'm terry martin here's a
recap of the top news this hour
ukrainian officials say russian forces
have seized the critical saporicia
nuclear power plant in the northeast of
the country which produces about a
quarter of ukraine's power
russian troops launched an attack on the
facility overnight leading to a fire at
the plant which is also europe's largest
ukraine's state emergency service says
it managed to put out the blaze and
secure
the plant safely authorities say that
radiation levels remain unchanged the
international atomic energy agency says
it has activated its full emergency
response mode because of the situation
at the plant
ukrainian president vladimir zolensky
has accused russia of trying to repeat
the chernobyl disaster saying the
incident underscores the need to stop
the fighting
if there's an explosion
that's the end for everyone the end for
europe
europe would have to be evacuated
only urgent action by europe can stop
the russian troops do not allow the
death of europe from a catastrophe at a
nuclear power plant
for more let's bring in dr charles casto
he's a u.s nuclear safety expert who is
involved in containing the fukushima
nuclear disaster in japan dr costa
thanks for being with us tell us what
went through your mind when you heard
that this ukrainian nuclear power plant
was on fire
well obviously terry that's a very
troubling situation that there is no
rational reason for uh attack on a
nuclear power plant
tell us how dangerous it is to have a
war being fought near a nuclear power
plant
well obviously
that situation is troubling however as
you've seen with the state media talking
about that it's stable the operators are
able to deal with these types of
situations we've planned for these
situations
and the design of the plan is very
robust nevertheless that is not a
challenge that you want to present to
anyone to any operator in any nuclear
facility anywhere
what exactly
do you have to watch out for i mean if
tanks are firing even if
if they're not targeting the plant
itself but somewhere near it if a shell
hits the nuclear power plant what could
happen
the most troubling situation would
likely be with the spent fuel that's
that's stored in the facility and that
spent fuel
is contained and has the containment
structure around it but nevertheless is
the part of the plant and part of the
fuel system that you would have to worry
about and we saw in the fukushima case
where they actually the earth attacked
the fukushima nuclear plant that the
operators were able to maintain safety
of the suspend fuel facility
is there any international arrests and
so
sorry go ahead sir the reactors have
felt obviously very well very robust and
contained uh deep in the plant and and
it would be difficult to have us to have
a
serious release however that's uh
something we always are concerned with
the spent fuel pools are somewhat more
concerning
and as i said that we have been shown
demonstrated that we can protect spent
fuel pools
is there any international safety
protocol for something like this for
nuclear power plants in conflict zones
the
iaea has a response center the
department of energy the nuclear
regulatory commission the united states
and many other agencies and they have
been activated uh to monitor the
situation and there is remote monitoring
of the radiation levels to be able to
determine the severity of the accident
or the concern that we have in ukraine
but it's not such that when when
fighting is happening around a nuclear
power plant it's not that they shut it
down
yes typically what would happen is
as if it was a hurricane or a tsunami
prior to that the plants would be shut
down and safely secured at that point
then all you then what you have left is
is the fuel itself
which
would be protected but the plant itself
would likely be shut down or would be
shut down by the loss of external power
outside the facility the plants are all
likely shut down and secured
now many people not just in ukraine
many people are scared about this
situation with ukraine's nuclear power
plants being in the middle of a war zone
should they be concerned
well you should be concerned the the uh
the likelihood of
uh it depends on the magnitude of any
attack that might occur the uh
and as i've said it's very extremely
robust the plant's extremely robust and
and uh mostly it would be a
area as we saw at chernobyl and
fukushima would be an area around the
plant that would be most
susceptible to damage
however after fukushima and after
chernobyl we learned a lot of lessons
from those accidents and learned many
countermeasures that we can take to
minimize the amount of radiation release
from a reactor regardless of the
accident that might occur
dr casto thank you very much that was dr
charles costo he's a u.s nuclear safety
expert
thank you terry
as you might expect condemnations of the
attack on the nuclear power plant have
been pouring in with world leaders
blasting russia's assault as reckless
in a tweet canadian prime minister
justin trudeau said the attacks must
cease immediately calling them quote
unacceptable
british prime minister boris johnson
also called for an immediate end to the
attacks on the nuclear plant demanding
that russia allow unfettered access for
emergency services
well for more let's bring in our chief
political correspondent melinda crane
melinda a nuclear power plant on fire in
ukraine this raises memories of of the
chernobyl nuclear disaster this is a
horrifying prospect for many people
absolutely and in fact this plant as you
know is the largest of its type in
europe a great deal larger than
chernobyl and you remember how far
excess radiation was detected after
chernobyl so indeed this is an
unprecedented attack that endangers not
just ukraine but the entire region and
potentially all of europe and uh people
are absolutely expressing outrage uh
boris johnson not only uh that statement
that that you just uh mentioned there
but in fact saying that we need to see
another meeting of the security council
of the united nations to talk about this
and uh and president zielenski as you
also said referring to this is nuclear
terror and calling on european leaders
to act now in theory and you and i have
talked about this before in theory the
entire attack on ukraine but certainly
this attack and by the way even if the
russians say that it was at most a
training facility that was affected here
nonetheless the danger is enormous this
attack would in theory trigger article
51 of the un charter which entitles
countries or groups of countries to
exercise an individual or collective
right of self-defense when the security
council has not or will not act until it
acts essentially will they do so
no definitely not
because that would
involve head-to-head confrontation with
russia the security council is not going
to act essentially it is paralyzed
because of russia's veto in the council
and without any security council
resolution no one else will act
particularly after the chilling
discussion that president macron had
yesterday with president putin where
putin made it clear he's prepared to
take this as he said to the end
speaking of calls for action the
the president of ukraine uh vladimir
zelinski he said he has called for a
no-fly zone over his country those calls
for a no-fly zone are getting quite loud
uh any chance of the of a new fly zone
being imposed by nato or the u.n no
again because there is fear that that
would provoke exactly the kind of
nuclear confrontation that uh nato and
uh hopefully russia want to
avoid so
a no-fly zone has in fact been imposed
in other conflicts iraq
bosnia libya
over a designated area the thing is it
has to be policed that means you have
fighter pilots up in the air ensuring
that the perimeter is not violated that
would mean a potential confrontation
between a nato fighter pilot and a
russian fighter pilot and don't don't
forget that those russian fighter pilots
they're hearing vladimir putin saying
that he's uh prosecuting this war in
order to prevent genocide and so on
that's what those fighter pilots have in
mind in that confrontation and therefore
what we've actually seen happen is nato
has now re-uh re-uh set its
de-confliction line that's the famous
red telephone the hotline of
communication with russian officials in
order to be sure we don't have
miscalculations that could trigger
escalation and certainly that's a reason
that they i think will not act on those
calls for a no-fly zone
mentioning nato uh nato foreign
ministers are meeting today in a special
session uh what can we expect there
melinda
more of the same we'll hear professions
of support for ukraine itself we will
hear professions of resolve in regard to
uh
article five of the nato treaty the
the collective
defense provisions we'll probably hear
more
announcements about what's being done to
shore up the defensibility of the
baltics and other vulnerable countries
and undoubtedly we'll hear more warnings
to vladimir putin himself will any of it
make a difference
who knows
melinda thank you very much for now our
political chief political corps